[Music]
there are a lot of mysteries in breath
of the wild many of which were left
unresolved after the credits rolled like
the origins of the Forgotten Temple the
giant Leviathan skeletons The Strange
Case of meccar Island and of course most
famously who were the zonai and what
happened to them but there's one mystery
in particular I've had an almost
unhealthy obsession with ever since
2017. the mystery of the eight heroines
despite my obsession I actually only
made one video about it because simply
put there wasn't enough information to
come to a satisfying conclusion it
really seems that the Zelda team
deliberately designed it such that it
would be an unsolvable case that is to
say unsolvable with just the information
presented by breath of the wild and its
complementary book creating a champion
which didn't explain much about them
either I even stated in my video that it
would be the last time I would look into
this mystery until the release of Tears
of the kingdom and the reason I said
this was because even if tears have the
kingdom does end up giving us the
answers We crave about the eight
heroines I assume that we would likely
need to you know play the actual game to
find out I didn't expect any significant
Clues to show up in the game's
promotional material however some of the
stuff we saw in the final trailer got my
Scooby-Doo census tingling once more and
so here we are again six months later
back to take one final crack at this
mystery
to keep the runtime of this video
somewhat manageable I'm gonna assume
that most of you know the details Behind
These Statues by now and only stick to
the cliff notes version if you're not
familiar there are tons of videos out
there that explain every little detail
you need to know about them including my
video from six months ago so in the
desert in breath of the wild we found
seven giant statues which by all
accounts are some of the most ancient
ruins found in Hyrule the architectural
style of the stonework and the
inscriptions reveal that they were built
by the Gerudo back in ancient times
nobody in the current day knows who each
individual statue is supposed to
represent it's a part of Gerudo history
that's been lost which is not surprising
I mean we're talking tens of thousands
of years what we do know based on the
inscriptions carved into them is that
they are memorials created in honor of a
group of individuals known as the seven
sages on the surface this isn't that big
of a deal there's quite a few references
to sages from past games all across
breath of the wild Hyrule be it names
that are derivative of sages structures
that symbolize or pay tribute to them in
some way even historical text that flat
out mentions some of them by name like
the Zora monuments which directly refer
to Princess Ruto from Ocarina of Time
over the years many have tried to
connect these statues to some of the
sages of old particularly the ones from
Ocarina which if you include Princess
Zelda amongst the seven however there's
not a lot to work with in terms of Hard
Evidence like I said there are
references to the sages of Ocarina but
then again the same goes for sages from
different games some of which didn't
show up in the Zelda Timeline until way
later and that's the thing sages have
appeared in various forms ages genders
races and in different numbers all
across the Zelda timeline and their
existence seems to work on the same
basic principle as the many incarnations
of Princess Zelda there's almost always
a blood connection involved to some
degree and when a sage awakens as it's
called they appear to inherit knowledge
and memories from past lives you could
say that sages are essentially Timeless
they continue to reincarnate and take on
new appearances so they can assist the
kingdom of Hyrule over the ages as such
it's hard to say which incarnation of
the seven sages these statues pay
tribute to or which historical event
they took part in it all depends on when
these statues were built which is
impossible to know for sure right now
thanks to creating a champion we know
that the Rocks placed around the
pedestal of the master sword are
depictions of the sages from Ocarina of
Time It's indisputable not only is there
no Rito present which makes sense since
the Rito didn't exist yet at the time
but the smallest rock is labeled as a
Kokiri and as we all know the Kokiri
transformed into the koroks shortly
after the events of Ocarina of Time and
stay that way for the remainder of
hyrule's History unfortunately this kind
of inductive reasoning cannot be applied
to the seven heroines the statues are
close to identical and carry No Labels
that infers a name or even a race that
said there is one important aspect about
the heroines that separates them from
all the other memorials and callbacks to
this ages there's a secret eighth
heroine this was a game changer because
as far as we know there's not a single
event in the original Zelda Timeline
where eight sages bonded together and A
Link Between Worlds there were seven
sages without Zelda included but Zelda
didn't play the role of a sage in that
story and so the total headcount still
amounts to seven regardless it's always
been no more than seven the fact that an
eighth almost identical statue exists
provides a solid case that the statues
of the heroines do not pay tribute to
any pre-established group of sages but
rather a new Ensemble we haven't seen or
met before this would place the
construction of the statue sometime
after the original Zelda Timeline but
still well before the Calamity from 10
000 years ago for a couple of reasons
first of all and this is one I've seen a
lot of confusion about Calamity Ganon is
not Ganondorf it's a phantom Ganondorf
created after he got sealed deep
underground unable to move he devised a
new strategy so he could continue to
wreak havoc on the world above by
forcing his malice to seep out from his
Frozen corpse it accumulates and
eventually forms into the ghostly
specter we saw soaring above the peaks
of Hyrule Castle this process of
building up malice is extremely slow
which is why after his Calamity was
successfully halted 10 000 years before
breath the wild it took him well ten
thousand years to unleash the next
Calamity which of course is the event we
saw in the memories the events of the
distant past depicted on the mural and
tears of the kingdom are much much older
than the Calamity from 10 000 years ago
in fact it seems to coincide with an
event listed in the timeline featured in
creating a champion where after having
been defeated many times before
referring to the original Zelda Timeline
Ganondorf finally lost it and
transformed into Calamity Ganon so when
someone says that this Mystery Lady
could be the princess on the tapestry
that is very unlikely these two events
took place many ages apart from each
other at least 10 000 years and tears of
the Kingdom's focus seems to be on these
events and not the ones from the
tapestry which finally brings us to the
clues found in the final trailer for
tears of the Kingdom in it we see a
character who based on his appearance is
the same individual who's depicted on
the ancient mural and the Seven orbs
that surround this mystery figure we now
know are the so-called tears of the
Kingdom powerful objects that are
attributed to certain individuals and
are likely this game's equivalent of the
main story collectible like the
medallions from Ocarina of Time across
the footage we can see various people
who are in possession of one of these
tiers including our favorite Chad
Ganondorf so far we've been able to
pinpoint six unique tiers in total and
based on the mural we can assume that
there is one more we just haven't seen
it yet where it gets confusing is that
there's a few instances where we can see
the same tier being held by different
individuals and this has everything to
do with the fact that and I can't
believe I'm saying this but yes tears of
the Kingdom most certainly features some
kind of time travel it seems that early
on in the story Zelda will be
transported to the ancient past where
she joins up with a new cast of
characters we haven't met before among
them is the creature portrayed on the
mural who can be seen interacting with
the princess in this sequence okay so I
want to be completely transparent about
this we do actually know the name of
this character but out of respect for
the ones who haven't seen the leaked art
book and want to keep it that way I will
not mention it here instead I will
shamelessly copy one of my fellow Zelda
theorists Bandit games and just call him
Richard over the course of the footage
it becomes pretty obvious what's going
on between these two timelines from what
we can gather there's essentially two
battles against Ganondorf taking place
simultaneously just in different time
periods Zelda joins the sages in the
ancient past and back in the present a
new group of sages is being recruited by
link for the fight against Ganondorf in
his time this explains why to the left
of Richard we can see an adult Rito
Warrior carrying the green tear on his
left foot or Talon I should say in the
same place where turlin wears his green
tear so basically Tulin is the
present-day equivalent or successor to
this ancient Rito Warrior and the same
will likely apply to riju saidon and
probably unobo if and when he decides to
show up from what I understand the
conflict in the past will eventually
lead to Ganondorf being sealed in fact
when you think about it it has to happen
or else it would create a paradox the
Ganondorf from the past cannot win he
cannot even be killed he must be sealed
if he doesn't then Link and Zelda would
never find his sealed corpse which also
means Zelda would never travel to the
past but she is in the past so
technically it already happened ah the
complexities of time travel anyway it's
the present where the outcome is
uncertain and with the masses who had
broken and the location of some of the
tears possibly lost in memory there's
very little standing in the way of a
victory for Ganondorf however Zelda
being stuck in the past presents a
unique opportunity to subtly influence
the outcome in Link's time not too
drastic of course like I said she cannot
just kill Ganondorf in her time but she
could for example provide information
like where the tears are located in the
present or helping to fix the master
sword in some way as long as the events
of the past lead to Ganondorf being
sealed it's okay but how this will be
accomplished and what Zelda's Mission
will be exactly is a subject for another
video in order to find out who the
eighth heroine is we need to map out who
the biggest players were in the time
period Zelda is in for the sake of
argument I'm gonna assume that Link's
contributions will mostly be confined to
the present so I'm leaving him out of it
this also eliminates the new sages who
are being assembled by him like riju
saidon toolin unobo and any other
potential characters who join the group
that said we can use the new sages as a
reference to determine who some of the
characters from the past were because so
far both riju and Tulin have a
corresponding predecessor who are of the
same race or faction and are wielding
the same weapons the aforementioned Rito
Warrior who wields the great Eagles bow
and a Gerudo who appears to brandish the
Scimitar of the seven the only Scimitar
we know of that has a red gem on the
hilt of the sword it is my belief that
team Richard is made up of eight people
in total seven sages plus Princess Zelda
five of these eight members have been
confirmed so far we have Richard and
Zelda the Rito and Gerudo and the
Mystery Lady some believe this is hylia
or even just Zelda with a makeover but
personally I don't think that's the case
while they do share similarities I think
she is her own character be it a distant
relative of Zelda or someone belonging
to the zonai or both it doesn't really
matter for today's subject all that
matters for now is that I regard Zelda
and this unknown lady as two separate
individuals I think it's a safe bet that
since there's a Rito and a Gerudo among
the group there's bound to be a Goron
and Zora as well in the case of the Zora
it's pretty much a given seeing as
saidon has one of the tears the blue one
in this case as for the gorons you may
remember that a couple of years ago the
Italian voice actor for The Rook
accidentally slipped up during an
interview and stated that he's voicing a
new Goron in his words a more serious
ancestor of The Rook back then we didn't
really know what to make of this since
we didn't have context but knowing what
we know now I'm starting to think that
he was probably referring to the Goron
Sage from the ancient past so let's run
with that this brings the current
headcount of Team richer to seven which
means we are only short one more member
then we have Ganondorf who some believe
might also be a sage since he does have
a tear of his own this age of Shadow or
Darkness perhaps who could have betrayed
the other six however I'm not on board
with that theory it kind of goes against
everything we know about this ages as I
explained earlier sages are Servants of
the light and the gods they are of a
similar stature as the light Spirits the
dragons and other types of spirit
Guardians Ganondorf is quite literally
the polar opposite of that he's a being
of hatred malice and darkness it would
be quite strange if he was a vessel for
one of the sages in part because he's
already kind of a vessel for demise not
to mention in team Richard we already
have a Gerudo Sage there are many
Alternatives as to why Ganondorf has one
of the tiers in his possession maybe he
stole it from one of the other factions
maybe he's hunting for the tears like
Thanos going after the Infinity Stones
it's not uncommon for Ganondorf to go
after sacred objects like how he tried
to force the Deku Tree the gorons and
Zora into giving him their spiritual
stones in Ocarina of Time in Twilight
Princess Ganondorf is in possession of
one of the most sacred swords out there
the sword of the six sages which he
stole from them I'm sure you don't have
to be a sage in order to use the tears
power these are just my thoughts of
course and I'm not bashing anyone who
thinks Ganondorf could be a sage I'm
just providing Alternatives based on my
own interpretations of the
pre-established lore as such it is my
belief that similar to the Unseen Goron
Sage there is one more who has eluded us
so far a representative of one of the
other factions in Hyrule perhaps and
given the history of the sages my money
is on either ashika who could possess a
purple Shadow tear or maybe a korok
though I think the sheikah are the more
likely candidate just bring my girl
paella into it come on Nintendo if there
is indeed one more that would bring team
richer to eight people eight sages who
bonded together a long time ago in an
effort to stop Ganondorf now you might
be wondering what about Zelda she's in
the past so couldn't she be the seventh
how do we know there's not six ancient
sages who teamed up with her well if you
look at the design of some of these
characters you might notice a pattern
Richard has one white tear painted onto
his nose if that is his nose Zelda has
two one under each eye and the Mystery
lady has a grand tone photo of eight
tears painted on her face I don't think
this is a coincidence and if it's not we
can safely assume that the other sages
will have their own unique numbers
attributed to them which is compelling
evidence that the group does indeed
consist of eight people in total without
having to throw Ganondorf into the mix
so after all that let's Circle Back To
The Mystery of the eight heroines it's
safe to say that the statues are most
likely memorials to team Richard which
one is which is hard to know for sure
since again the statues are pretty much
identical and nameless an archaeologist
in town does mention a list of abilities
each individual is set to have possessed
but they are quite abstract to say the
least like skill for example whatever
that means there are a few that are more
obvious like flight being tied to the
Rito Spirit to the Gerudo knowledge May
refer to Zelda or maybe this guy given
his third eye which often symbolizes
some sort of Clairvoyance endurance may
have something to do with the sturdiness
of the gorons motion possibly refers to
the power of recall and perhaps
gentleness shares a connection to a kind
of healing ability like we saw with mifa
but these are best guesses and there's
no way to know for sure until we see
these ancient sages in action so instead
let's focus solely on the eighth heroine
I'll quickly say that I am aware that
there are theories out there that
Ganondorf could be the eighth heroine
but instead of spending another two
minutes on that now I'd rather present
my own conclusion first and then address
the Ganondorf Theory at the end because
as you may have guessed I don't think
it's him so out of all the individuals
that make up team Richard which one is
the eighth heroine the easy answer would
obviously be the mystery woman after all
she wears the number eight on her face
not only that but if she is a zonai a
tribe who is said to have disappeared
then it would make sense that she is the
missing eighth another candidate would
be Richard out of all the characters in
the group he seems to be the one who
ends up making the ultimate sacrifice
and seals Ganondorf in place he's the
only one who wears a bracelet like the
one we saw in the green hand latched
onto ganondorf's body he's also huge
especially compared to Zelda and in the
2019 footage we saw brief flash of
ganondorf's Final Moments right before
his imprisonment now Ganondorf is
already a big guy and yet the size of
the arm that reaches out to him suggests
an individual who's as big if not bigger
than he is this means that the image we
see here is what remains of Richard
after thousands of years of keeping
Ganondorf pinned down it's quite morbid
actually and if he's been down here for
Millennia with Ganondorf someone whose
existence has also been forgotten it
presents a pretty solid case that
Richard could beat a missing Sage but as
you may have guessed I think neither of
these two are the eighth heroine because
the way I see it the statues were likely
built shortly after the battle against
Ganondorf was over you know to
commemorate those who took part in this
world-changing event so even if either
of these two die or disappear during or
after the battle then at the time they
would still be fresh in everyone's
memory surely they would have been
remembered through eyewitness accounts
or perhaps by their fellow sages if some
of them end up Surviving the battle
there has to be a more sensible reason
as to why one of the eight Pages would
have been wiped from history as it's
been described which is why I think that
the eighth heroine is none other than
Zelda and the more you think about it
the more it starts to make sense out of
all these people Zelda is the only one
who doesn't belong in this time period
in fact her being there is the only
reason why it was possible to have eight
sages in the same place as opposed to
the traditional seven there were
essentially two zeldas taking place in
the same fight they would have had every
reason to treat her separately and keep
her identity a secret I think we can all
agree that link will eventually win the
fight against Ganondorf in the present
right I mean this is Zelda we're talking
about well that victory was made
possible by Zelda's contributions in the
ancient past from the vantage point of
the people who built these statues back
then that future outcome of ganondorf's
defeat hasn't happened yet and so the
less people know about a time traveling
princess who was there and made it all
possible the better the chances that
that future remains secure we can also
assume that at some point in the story
Zelda will return to her own time and
when she does she is quite literally
wiped from history the same way the hero
of time became non-existent after Zelda
sent him back in time to relive his
childhood in hindsight the nature of the
statue itself also hides many clues
about its true identity one of the key
aspects that differentiates the eighth
heroine statue from the other seven is
that it's a mirror opposite what I mean
by that is that for some reason the
in-game model for the Statue textures
and all has been flipped it's a detail
that has puzzle theorists ever since it
was first discovered because they didn't
have to do that the statue would have
fit on the side of this mountain just
fine mirrored or not mirrored so why go
through the effort of flipping the model
however in context with the story of
Tears of the kingdom it suddenly makes a
lot of sense all across the board we've
seen a recurring theme of mirror
opposites like two opposite tears two
dragons facing each other or devouring
each other's tail the strange reverse
vocals we keep hearing in all of the
footage back when we didn't know much
about the game's story yet we theorized
that it could have something to do with
the duality of Highly Zelda or the
endless curse of demise or something
like that but it seems we were
completely off the theme of mirror
opposite seems to refer to the
connection between these two different
time periods and the biggest giveaway
for me is the two opposing tears I
believe that these represent the recall
tier all the other tiers allegedly stay
in their own time period in the hands of
their contemporary sages the recall tier
is different it's the only tear who at
least for a little while exists as a
duplicate in the same time period the
one Zelda has which originates from the
present and the one that was already in
the past which looks to be in possession
of The Other Woman They even carry them
in the same way on the necklace another
possible connection between Zelda and
the eighth heroine is that unlike the
other statues it doesn't have a sword in
hand and seemingly never did the sword
does exist but it's found further up the
mountain and has been dubbed the
Forgotten sword in some of the new
footage we see that Zelda has the broken
master sword with her meaning that it
was somehow sent into the past with her
if Zelda returns to her own time and
some point it's safe to say that the
sword will too and thus it'll be wiped
from history along with her so perhaps
the missing sword may be a reference to
that I mean it is literally called The
Forgotten sword I think it would be a
fitting and poetic answer to the mystery
of the eighth heroine an individual who
didn't belong yet was still memorialized
in secret for her contributions and so
they constructed it far away from the
other seven in a place not many people
are likely to set foot in here it stood
for thousands of years and only those
with the knowledge of the ancient past
would be able to know its true meaning
if I end up being right about this it
would tie surprisingly well into my
previous theory about the eighth heroine
in that video I suggest that the dragons
are paying their respects to the Statue
mainly because some of their flight
paths seem to coincide with its location
I won't go into further detail about
that here just watch the video if you're
interested I guess but with this new
conclusion in mind that the eighth
heroine is a memorial to Zelda then I
could be right about the dragons too
after all if there's anyone who would
have been alive in the the time period
Zelda was stuck in and still remembers
her contributions in the present day it
would be them since they are essentially
Immortal there's even a theory floating
around that Richard's true form is that
of a dragon which has some compelling
evidence going for it so before I wrap
things up let's quickly talk about
Ganondorf being the eighth heroine for
me this idea doesn't work very well
especially in context with the other
seven statues the idea seems to stem
from the same Theory we talked about
before that he himself was a sage and
may have betrayed the other seven and
that this is why his statue was secreted
away but as I said before the statues
were most likely built after the battle
between the sages and Ganondorf was over
so then why would they still choose to
pay tribute to a guy who essentially
tried to enact genocide on everyone and
by they I'm of course referring to the
Gerudo the stonework of the eighth
heroine has all the characteristics of
Gerudo culture they are the only ones
who build statues that look like this
and continue to do so in the current day
and the Gerudo were clearly not on board
with Ganondorf unless of course the 7
and the eighth were made by different
factions maybe an offshoot of the Gerudo
who were loyal to Ganondorf and managed
to survive the war but then how do we
explain this place in the present day it
serves as a hideout for the yiga clan
but creating a champion confirms that it
was originally an ancient Gerudo
archaeological site it looks like it
used to be a secret Shrine of some kind
seeing as it was carved inside the
mountains hidden from plain sight it
features eight statues standing in a
circle and the way I see it there's only
two options either the Gerudo who were
against Ganondorf built it which means
they were well aware of the existence of
the eighth sage and included them with
the other seven it wouldn't make a lot
of sense if that Sage was Ganondorf
their enemy the other option is that the
quote-unquote evil Gerudo constructed
this place those who were loyal to
Ganondorf which raises the question of
why would they build statues to all
eight of them including the seven who
defeated him you would expect to see
something more along the lines of a side
of worship solely devoted to Ganondorf
last but not least despite the eighth
heroine statue to being a mirror
opposite the inscriptions still read
seven sages you know the people who
defeated Ganondorf I don't know about
you but if I ever get a statue in my
honor I sure as heck hope they don't
inscribe it with my biggest enemies but
that's just me of course actually one
more thing as I was recording this
Nintendo of Japan posted a new video
which actually features a shot of the
seven heroines or should I say four
heroines since three statues are missing
actually two are missing you can see the
fifth one but it's very hard to see
without upping the contrast for those
who are curious I posted a tweet about
It featuring some mad scribbles and some
very bad grammar it doesn't seem to have
anything to do with the time travel
aspect like they killed some of the
sages in the past and now there's only
five statues instead the answer seems to
be a lot more grounded it looks like
there's a sinkhole that formed in the
center approximately where the shrine
used to be we know Cinco's our thing in
tears of the Kingdom in fact the ones
you see here are at the Eastern Barons
which is actually quite close to the
seven statues the sinkhole seems to be
dragging the statues in slowly consuming
them so there you go anyway that about
does it for this one as always thank you
so much for watching it wasn't easy
coming up with the subject because not
only is there just so much to cover but
new information kept getting out as I
was working on this which was kind of
frustrating not to mention my fellow
Zelda creators are all killing it right
now which is just so awesome to see that
said I hope I was able to bring
something to the table here and if not
then well at least I tried that is all
for today and I hope to see you all next
time
[Music]